so now i would like to welcome mr elia
brotherski one of the co-founder and ceo
of find biotech to talk about omics
logic and how can we prepare the next
generation of experts that bring deep
insights from biological data using data
science skills and also how can we
advance the experience these students
have placing them at the forefront of
big data that continues to grow with
increased complexity and scale
mr brodsky has facilitated and managed
collaborations with researchers at
stanford ucsf louisiana state university
tulane and other academic and pharma r d
teams mr bronski oversees the research
projects and manages the development of
the prototype preparation of the
relevant data projects and
implementation of the systems for the
needs of students and teachers that the
project is designed for
now i would like to pass on the stage to
mr india over to you india
okay thank you very much
and again thank you for everyone that
was here up until now
so we're going to transition now from
the previous presenters we had a great
panelists and speakers from india we had
great panelists and speakers from africa
and so now we're going to be moving on
to the main part of the symposium where
we will be talking to
a number of experts
on the changing role of bioinformatics
in research industry and education
continuing with the theme of today so
briefly before we begin that i wanted to
thank all of the speakers and we had uh
great experts from
all of these places it was great to hear
some of the insights that everybody
shared so just kind of some takeaways
that i had from this
we heard about the pressing need
to review annotate and improve data
quality
both the ones that are available in
future data sets that will be shared so
i think dr raghava really highlighted
the significance of publicly available
data sets and the importance of
involving students and
other
kind of stakeholders
in being able to
contribute to that process of annotation
we also heard about industry-driven
education in indian health care so we
talked about we heard
how
industry
has a great demand for data science
skills and skilled workers in a variety
of fields in india especially this
requires a collaboration a close
collaboration
with
industry and
i i think it was really interesting to
hear about all of that
we also heard
from the africa team
about their
efforts
to address the gap
especially training biologists and
addressing some of the pressing
challenges in the african continent and
including infectious diseases cancer
chronic and metabolic diseases so that
was really insightful and of course we
also heard from dr anita ganza from
university of ghana
speaking about the important work that
they are doing in monitoring the
diversity of the malaria pathogen and
how that affects drug resistance
including the upcoming vaccination
effort so
this was really a global perspective i
think on the changing role of
bioinformatics but also on some of the
upcoming needs in bioinformatics
training and education and so really
thank you all for sharing all of those
insights with us
so briefly i know that many of you here
today are already familiar with what we
do
but in short
what we've seen up until now
are some of the people that we partner
with including expert bioinformaticians
and researchers in a variety of domains
that essentially provide us with an
opportunity to take publicly available
data sets and turn them into case
studies to allow students to explore and
understand both the challenges that they
present
and practice the analysis path to
essentially extract
meaningful insights from complex omics
data and so the projects that we
see
are examples of how anyone can start a
applying bioinformatics in oncology in
infectious diseases in neuroscience and
agriculture all very pressing domains uh
not only in the west but also
in a lot of these countries around the
world
briefly i want to also introduce that
today with us we will have an
opportunity to speak
and hear
from experts
the first group that i would like to
introduce are
the tower bioinformatics research center
so
university of haifa is where the talbot
bioinformatics research center was
established essentially
two goals that i understand that they
are pursuing
one is to develop novel algorithms for
multi-almonds integration
and number two to really make
bioinformatics more accessible by making
it use user user-friendly by making it
uh
explained and logical to use and i i
think that's a major gap in a lot of the
educational especially educational
activities around the world is that a
lot of the focus in bioinformatics
education is on technical skills and
unfortunately technical skills are not
the only skills that are important it we
have this kind of multiple challenges
emerging in the field of bioinformatics
where
there's a need for translational
research as highlighted by the pandemic
we see kind of the translation of ideas
that have
emerged from experimental
design
in cell lines and tissues and animal
models and now reaching patients kind of
pressing need with patient health
we also see the challenge in data
integration because so many omics data
types have emerged and evolved over the
recent years because the data has become
so uh cheap to generate in one sense and
in another sense it can address so many
different aspects of molecular biology
there's definitely a need for data
integration but at the bottom level
right so kind of supporting the logic of
bioinformatics
are asking the right questions and
finding answers using appropriate
methods for data analysis and so in that
domain
i think it is very important and
critical
some of the work that the tower
bioinformatics research center is doing
and so what they have designed is a
platform called the tbionfo platform
that combines multiple types of
user-friendly analysis pipelines to
integrate
analyze
visualize and interpret some of these
important data sets that are
typically used in the domain of
bioinformatics
so one of the exciting things that i'm
looking forward to in a few minutes
after
my part of the presentation is to really
hear about some of the new advances in
the different types of onyx technologies
that also come with the need to develop
and design
new algorithms to process and integrate
such data
and so this includes a range of new
bioinformatics sections that are either
being added or or planned to be added
for single cell data analysis and
integration
for analysis and uh modeling of kins or
cell mutations and also mathematical
modeling for host pathogen interaction
as well as exciting new applications of
mathematical modeling and simulation for
a variety
of challenges in life science research
so what we have done on our side at the
pine biotech side is we have taken a lot
of these sections and tools and methods
that have been made in a user-friendly
interface and connected logically and
turn them into educational modules that
anyone can learn from
both being exposed to the topic domain
to the significance and the importance
of that domain to the pressing
challenges in that domain and with
associated
case studies and methods of analysis
that could be practiced in a logical way
as well as technical way
so one of those domains that we hear a
lot about and we heard already today
is the concept of personalized medicine
so this field has seen dramatic growth
and as a result of
different types of molecular data
large-scale repositories of patient
records and many new computational
technologies that now allow for fast
processing for easy analysis and
integration and importantly the ability
to ask very specific questions about
patient health and so while there's a
lot of potential in this field there are
also many challenges that we will hear
about today and these include challenges
to integrate multi-omics data challenges
and gaps in the ability to
access different types of data and
phenotypic data that is very critical
for interpretation and many different
questions about the statistical
significance
and interpretation of found signals that
cannot be exhaustively addressed using
just experimental data and so there is a
need for mathematical modeling and
simulation
and so we hope that some of the modules
that we design are going to be an
opportunity for students that
guidance and ability to enter
into a particular domain like precision
medicine
to be able to effectively use
bioinformatics and contribute to such
areas
another area that we will hear about
today and we of course have heard about
uh for uh the duration of the past
couple of years
is the emerging
awareness of bioinformatics in
infectious diseases so uh that is
something that the pandemic has really
brought about to the awareness of the
public
the general public today knows
what is a mutation what is the variant
of concern
how does the virus evolve
as we observe transmission right so a
lot of interesting questions that from
being
kind of explored in the lab setting by
only experts now is the in the domain of
the public of the public discussion of
the mass media
and so that makes it even much more
critical for anyone to understand what
goes into the data that is being
generated and analyzed and presented
what goes into the actual interpretation
of the signals found in this data and so
i think that this is an important area
for us to continue to explore and what
we have designed around these areas
is a whole specialization track
dedicated to infectious diseases where
we talk about the application of
bioinformatics to infectious disease
research and the understanding of host
pathogen interaction
based on viral infection bacterial fungi
and parasites and so a lot of the
examples that we have heard about like
malaria a lot of the ones that we will
hear about today like covet 19 and other
types of viruses
another interesting domain is i think
many of the people in the kind of
medical domain don't really or
biomedical research domain don't
appreciate maybe as much as the area of
omics and agrobiology
where there's a lot of technology that
is driving this concept of precision
agro technology to address the need of
global food supply the changing climate
the need for
more resistant crops that are
going to be adapted to new regions
and so this area has been seeing a
tremendous interest as well
and so one of the important challenges
for us is to design
modules that could address some of the
pressing challenges and opportunities in
agrobiology so
we already have some examples but we
will continue to expand this working
with other partners to kind of
supplement the materials that we already
have
another important area
that i recently learned about is the
domain of astrobiology
and while astrobiology and in general
omix data and astrobiology have been
around for quite some time
the recent advances in space exploration
right the commercially available flights
the
hype around
maybe exploring mars and sending people
to mars or sending people to space has
really i think
fascinated a lot of students
has really provided an opportunity to
talk about some of the challenges how do
we actually explore space on longer
flights what what is needed and what
kind of studies are needed today to
understand the dangers and the methods
to kind of overcome some of those
challenges with microgravity with
radiation with all kinds of effects of
space flight that maybe
we need to think about before we can
plan out some of these longer missions
um i think it's a very interesting
domain and so today we will hear from
some of the experts and some of the
people that represent the student
community that are working together to
ask questions and use publicly available
data sets to be able to
kind of explore this whole topic
now all of these specialization tracks
require some practical and basic
training as well and so one of our
missions as a company is to really
provide an opportunity for anyone coming
from a life science background or coming
from a
kind of an engineering technical
background to be able to get involved in
such studies and so as a result we've
designed basic modules that are
specifically designed to introduce
the domain of bioinformatics or the
integration between
biology and data and we have modules on
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics and practical
exercises in data science skills and so
i think that what we are trying to
address through these modules is to
really uh kind of address the gap that
we see in this field and one of the
things that we've learned is that there
is a gap
between the ability to
generate data and the ability to analyze
and use information that comes out from
that data and that gap has multiple
different challenges right that we heard
about today already
data annotation availability of data
availability of tools so many different
things but the specific thing that we
see that is of the biggest concern is
the ability to analyze this complex data
and so as a result we are now working
with universities to really address that
gap by providing uh the missing elements
from what we see as the missing elements
in that kind of a curriculum
sorry so those missing elements include
mentorship
from experts in the field that are
available through
the kind of guidance and oversight of
project development
we see a gap in infrastructure so that
anyone can analyze larger and more
complex data sets independently and of
course there's a need to work together
with faculty to align such training with
the needs of different domains and
different types of departments and so
that is really what we're working on
right now and so we haven't just started
now but we've done several different
pilots to validate this approach and
this technology we've done a number of
pilot programs with the louisiana
biomedical research network kind of
hosted at the louisiana state university
with work with
georgetown university where we've
worked with the systems medicine program
where they kind of talk about the
clinical applications of bioinformatics
and we've worked with international
universities like the amity university
in
india where they have a number of
programs in biotechnology that really
need the bioinformatics training not as
a core subject but really as a subject
that could be implemented as a part of
the standard biotechnology
training and so in today's webinar in
today's sessions and tomorrow sessions
we will hear from a lot of these
programs about lessons learned you know
how does this work well uh in in terms
of where is this going where is the need
in the future for this kind of a domain
and also how can we prepare the students
not only to know what they need to know
today but also what kinds of skills they
will need in the next five to ten years
when they will become the leaders
of bioinformatics and so um we have a
lot of interesting participating
organizations that we will hear from
today that we already heard from some of
them up until now and of course we are
looking forward to today's sessions and
also tomorrow to hear about not only
what you can learn from some of the
training that we provide but also to get
a degree
in this area in this field
so
to summarize onyx logic is a program
that is designed to enable independent
research guided by mentors and peer
example and we are excited to see that
we have over 10 000 students learning in
different programs that we have
and we expect this number to continue to
grow as the need for bioinformatics is
expanding
we
see a need to kind of develop this
growing community by partnering with
other organizations and with uh kind of
establishing local chapters and so
that's why you heard today from our
team in india from our team in africa
and we want to hear from all of you if
you are interested to expand this
network as well
and our ultimate goal is to enable
students clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research projects using
latest technology and life and data
science so really combining them
together
and one of the things that we will
finish off with today
is we will speak about
uh some of the future programs that we
are designing that i think are changing
the nature of bioinformatics
as you probably all know there is kind
of this shift in terminology for example
up until now bioinformatics was seen as
this niche domain and i think that with
the advances in data science and the
need for data skills
in other areas
bioinformatics is now kind of being
rebranded almost as a data science for
biological data so one of the things
that we are developing is a
comprehensive curriculum designed to
kind of address uh this change as well
where
we have upcoming programs on data
science in uh for big data and for
data skills that include statistical
analysis and machine learning
kind of addressing the challenges in
experimental design and technical
validation
for data mining and finding meaningful
patterns and associations and complex
data and to apply this to systems
biology
studies so the way that we typically do
this
just
kind of to tell you about the format
is really pandemic ready right so one of
our goals is to make this
as a bridge between
what people can do asynchronously and
what happens in a typical university
setting so we can adapt and kind of
integrate modules on different types of
omics data different types of
specialization tracks different types of
levels from very technical to more
conceptual
and kind of
provide some interactive sessions with
experienced mentors that can guide
students to
apply these skills in a meaningful way
and i think the biggest validation
that we see for this work
is in the completed projects so not only
do we think that the training the
technical skills are needed but
ultimately the proof is when somebody
can apply
some of the skills that they have
learned to a real interesting project